A
CRIMINAL COMPLAINT.
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY --
>> BUCKINGHAM PALACE AND THE
LEGAL TEAM OF BRITAIN'S PRINCE
ANDREW REFUSING TO COMMENT ON
NEW SEXUAL ABUSE LAWSUITS.
IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME
ALLEGATIONS HAVE COME TO LIGHT,
BUT IN THE PAST, THERE HAVE
BEEN STRENUOUS DENIALS.
NINO DOS SANTOS HAS THE REPORT.
THIS IS VIRGINIA DUFRESNE
AROUND THE TIME SHE SAYS SHE
WAS FORCED TO HAVE SEX WITH
PRINCE ANDREW.
A PHOTO TAKEN AT THE LONDON
HOUSE OF SOCIAL LIKE LANE
MAXWELL, FACING TRIAL FOR
PROCURING MINORS FOR THE LATE
PEDOPHILE JEFFREY EPSTEIN,
CHARGES SHE HAS PLED NOT GUILTY
TO.
WHEN THE SHOT WAS SNAPPED IN
2001, SHE WAS JUST 17.
PRINCE ANDREW WAS AROUND 40.
>> HE KNOWS WHAT HAPPENED.
I KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
THERE IS ONLY ONE OF US TELLING
THE TRUTH, AND I KNOW THAT'S
ME.
>> IN A CIVIL SUIT FILED THIS
WEEK IN NEW YORK, GUIFFRE
ALLEGES THE PRINCE ABUSED HER
IN 3 LOCATIONS, INCLUDING AT
EPSTEIN'S MANSION IN MANHATTAN,
AND ON HIS PRIVATE CARIBBEAN
ISLAND.
SHE SAYS THE PRINCE KNEW SHE
WAS UNDERAGE AND SHE HAD BEEN
TRAFFICKED THERE.
THE COMPLAINT FILED UNDER STATE
PROTECTION LAWS --
FIRST DESCRIBED IN 2015 AND
SEEKS DAMAGES IN AN AMOUNT TO
BE DETERMINED AT TRIAL.
PRINCE ANDREW'S LEGAL TEAM
DECLINED TO COMMENT ON THE
DEVELOPMENT.
IN THE PAST, THE ROYAL HAS
STRENUOUSLY DENIED HE HAS EVER
MET HER, AND HAS SUGGESTED THE
PHOTO OF THEM TOGETHER COULD BE
FAKE.
>> I CAN ABSOLUTELY
CATEGORICALLY TELL YOU IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
>> DO YOU RECALL ANY KIND OF
SEXUAL CONTACT WITH VIRGINIA
ROBERTS THAN OR ANY OTHER TIME?
>> NONE WHATSOEVER.
>> PRINCE ANDREW OFFERED TO
COOPERATE WITH INVESTIGATORS IN
2019 IN THIS DISASTROUS TV
INTERVIEW, AND HAS SINCE
REPEATED THAT PLEDGE, IN A
WRITTEN STATEMENT, WHEN
RESIGNING FROM ROYAL DUTIES.
HER LAWYERS SAY HE HAS BEEN
STONEWALLING SENSE.
FOR THIS AUTHOR WHO'S WRITTEN A
BOOK ON THE PRINCE AND EPSTEIN,
THE LEGAL DRAMA IS MAKING IT
UNLIKELY ANDREW WILL MAKE IT
BACK IN THE ROYAL FOLD SOON.
>> THE NEW CIVIL LAWSUIT FROM
VIRGINIA WIN GIUFFRE, IT
PRECLUDES PRINCE ANDREW FROM
RETURNING TO PUBLIC DUTIES.
IT'S DIFFERENT TO SEE HOW IT'S
COME BACK TO THE FRONTLINE OF
THE MONARCHY, WITH THIS SUIT
PENDING, OR IF THERE IS A COURT
THAT FINDS AGAINST HIM IN
ABSENTIA.
>> BUCKINGHAM PALACE TO CLIMBED
TO COMMENT ON THE SUIT.
NEWS OF FRESH LITIGATION
HIGHLIGHTS UNCOMFORTABLE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PRINCE'S
RELATIONSHIP WIT